there is an accounting program in new
york
for promising students who want to get
better at accounting
so campus reforms ben zeissloft who also
writes for the daily wire
just to put this this report out about
the career opportunities
in the accounting profession program
this is sponsored by the new york state
society
of cpas certified public accountants and
the moynihan scholarship fund
and it is meant for 250 promising high
school students
and if you want to apply to that you can
so long as you're black
or hispanic or asian i think asians are
allowed to apply
not totally sure the one thing i do know
is if you're white you're not allowed to
apply
this is a program designed to give
people a leg up in
accounting but white people are not
permitted to apply
because we have a system of legal racism
in this country
just like the left says there is
systemic racism
and that systemic racism the only legal
racism in this country
is against white people and to some
degree asian people
and it's most notable in affirmative
action but you see it in places like
this
as well now this this is hosted by
a bunch of very prominent institutes and
colleges in new york
ithaca college medgar evers college
rochester institute of technology rit
siena college st john's university suny
newpoli oswego
these are state universities too the
university of buffalo and westchester
community college not too far from where
i grew up
this is your taxpayer dollars
going toward hosting an event that's
being done in association with these
other
institutes that will not permit white
people in
why because it would be we are now
living in a regime that says it's bad to
give
the same opportunities to white people
as there are to black people and
hispanic people and asian people
and that's that and they'll they'll tell
you this if you push them hard enough
they'll say well yeah because
black people have been disadvantaged
where it gets a little strange
however is i do see the argument you say
look
certain people came here on the
mayflower certain people came here on
slave ships
and we recognize that there is a sort of
force to history
and because of that we're trying to
write historical wrongs i'm not saying i
agree with that argument but i at least
understand it black people do constitute
the black descendants of slaves
does constitute a sort of special case
in the united states
but what about the immigrants why are we
treating people
who either came here voluntarily or or
descended from people who came here
voluntarily
the same way that we're treating people
who came here or whose ancestors came
here
on slave ships why why are we pretending
that immigrants are oppressed
immigrants chose to come here and they
chose to come here largely to give their
progeny a better life why are we
pretending that they're oppressed
that's insane if you if this is such an
impressive place don't come here
if the immigrants thought this was a
terribly oppressive place they wouldn't
have come here
but they did so i could almost
understand the argument if you said this
is only for black people
it's still again i'm not saying i agree
with it i'm just saying i understand it
but now we're saying okay and hispanics
too hispanics get a leg up and white
people aren't allowed to apply
why they came here voluntarily and their
rather their ancestors came here
voluntarily
and thousands of them are coming here
voluntarily every single day pouring
illegally across the border
why are we pretending that america has
been un so unjust
and bigoted toward these people the
people who are who are begging pleading
to come here and breaking our laws to do
it
very often that is not particularly
coherent
unless you're living in a racist regime
that says white people bad other people
good
white people bad to a lesser degree
asian people bad everyone else good
that that is the racial regime that
we're living under and it's no surprise
that people think that race relations
are getting worse and worse oh hey you
nice to see you
i wish i could see you more often i wish
i could see you more
reliably and the way that i can do that
is if you ring that bell ring that bell
subscribe like that way you will be able
to get the notifications
head on over to apple podcast spotify
google play stitcher
myspace xanga aol instant messenger
subscribe to
the audio podcast the michael nelson
leave a five-star review we'd really
appreciate it
i'll see you next time and i'll miss you
until then